That got me thinking about,
or an article that I read about Anthony Bourdain and Anthony Bordain.
Obviously he was about as successful as as anyone could be.
I mean,
he was a successful guy in so many aspects and yet,
and yet he killed himself
and I didn't know him personally,
but you know,
he knew people that I know,
you know,
he was,
he was friends with Joe Rogan.
He was,
he was friends with Harley Flanagan.
He was friends with guys that,
guys that are really good guys.
And so in that way I kind of felt like I knew what kind of a guy who was at
least,
and even from the outside,
even without having any connections to them at all,
he was the kind of guy that had just about everything that,
that,
that most people would want.
And
even still,
I mean,
obviously that wasn't enough.
Well,
in the article that I read,
there was a quote from one of Anthony Bourdain's books in the book was called a
cook's tour.
He said,
in this book,
I wanted adventure.
I wanted to go up the known river to the heart of darkness.
In Cambodia.
I wanted to ride out into a desert on camelback sand and dunes in every
direction.
Eat whole roasted lamb with my fingers.
I wanted to kick snow off my boots in a Mafia nightclub in Russia.
I wanted to play with automatic weapons in Phnom Penh.
Recapture the past in a small oyster village in France.
Step into a CD,
neon lit pool,
Korea in rural Mexico.
I want it to run roadblocks in the middle of the night.
Blowing past angry militia with a hand full of hurled marble packs.
Yeah.
Experience.
Fear,
excitement,
wonder.
I wanted kicks.
The kind of melodramatic thrills and chills I yearned for since childhood
kind of adventure I'd found as a little boy in the pages of my tin,
tin comic books.
I wanted to see the world and I wanted the world to be just like the movies.
That's what Anthony Bourdain said.
Just like the movies.
Okay.
Hmm.
But you know what?
To me,
cool
old is not like the movies.
The movies aren't real.
They don't exist,
but you do.
And life,
this life is,
it's better than any movie there is.
Movies are supposed to provoke emotion.
They're supposed to make you feel something,
but I have a better idea.
Go out into the world and actually feel it.
Go feel joy and love and triumph and rapture and ecstasy and glory.
Go feel those things.
And you know with those feelings,
there will be other feelings as well.
There'll be sorrow and pain and sadness and desolation and suffering.
There'd be a whole those feelings too.
But you know what?
That's okay.
Take both sides.
Feel all of it.
That's what life is.
Those feelings,
those emotions,
those highs and vose,
Lowe's,
those are life
and those emotions and those feelings are better than any movie because they are
real.
So make your own
comic book,
Make Your Life,
your own movie.
Actually make it better than a movie.
Not,
not better because it's more adventurous or more romantic or more melodramatic.
Make it better
because it's real.
It's real.
So it is better.
And you know what?
Real combs with some downsides
where you comms with some darkness.
Okay,
but that's okay.
It's okay.
Because when you know the darkness,
yeah,
the light becomes even brighter.
So go out there,
move toward the light move.
Yeah.
Toward
the light
and live,
live.